Robert Spencer here for Jihad watch a
program of the David haritz Freedom
Center and the center for security
policy with some important information
about the shadowy and Powerful
organization known as the Muslim
Brotherhood an organization that many
oddly enough think is our best hope
against terrorism is the Muslim
Brotherhood a terrorist organization or
one of the world's foremost bulwarks
against terrorism numerous mainstream
terrorism an analysts in Washington
contend that it is the latter but they
have to ignore a mountain of evidence to
do so arguing recently in the Washington
Post that Congress should not designate
the Muslim Brotherhood a terrorist
organization Mark Lynch of the George
Washington University and the project on
Middle East political science asserts
that the Muslim brotherhood's firewall
against extremism was what he calls a
very real thing in the decade following
9/11 but now because of the acisi
government's Crackdown on the
Brotherhood the key mechanisms by which
the firewall operated have now
dramatically eroded Lynch notes that
prior to the Arab Uprising I argue that
is Lynch that mainstream islamists
served as a firewall against more
violent extremists this was because he
said the Brotherhood publicly
articulated an ideology of non-violence
and Democratic participation it competed
with Al-Qaeda for recruits and for
public influence and kept its members
tightly embedded within its
institutional structures the Brotherhood
could compete he said with Al-Qaeda and
Other Extreme groups in ways that
liberals and state Elites could not now
apparently Lynch is unaware that the
founders of al-Qaeda Abdullah aam and
Osama Bin Laden as well as its current
leader Iman aari were all members of or
trained by the Muslim Brotherhood even
more importantly in building his case
that the Muslim brother is a competitor
to and bullwark against Al-Qaeda and
other Jihad Terror groups Lynch ignores
the fact that the Muslim Brotherhood and
Al-Qaeda have exactly the same goal in
his 2002 letter to the American people
Osama Bin Laden wrote the first thing
that we are calling you to is Islam and
criticizes the US for not conforming to
Islamic law he wrote you are the nation
who rather than by ruling by the Sharia
of Allah and its Constitution and laws
choose to invent your own laws as you
will and desire you separate religion
from your policies contradicting the
pure nature which affirms absolute
authority to the Lord and your creator
now the Muslim Brotherhood shares that
goal of replacing Democratic rule with
Sharia as even CNN acknowledged in 2013
when it wrote the Muslim Brotherhood is
a religious and political group founded
on the belief that Islam is not simply a
religion but a way of life it Advocates
a move away from secularism and a return
to the rules of the Quran as a basis for
Healthy Families communities and states
the key difference between the Muslim
Brotherhood and Al-Qaeda and other Jihad
groups is that the Brotherhood Works
through the Democratic process in order
to undermine that process and ultimately
destroy it while the jihadis violently
attack the installations of democratic
governments in order to weaken and
ultimately destroy them for Lynch and
other Washington po policy analysts this
is an all important distinction but in
reality it is a distinction without a
difference the Brotherhood and the Jihad
groups are two sides of the same coin
working for the same goal via different
means what's more the assertion that the
Brotherhood isues violence isn't even
accurate Lynch claims that and I quote
despite post coup propaganda and arrests
by the Egyptian regime there is very
little to substantiate the charge that
the Brotherhood behaved like a terrorist
organization during Egypt's transition
or raised violence either ideologically
or
strategically but reality again explodes
Beltway fantasy Egypt's El Nadim Center
for rehabilitation of victims of
violence documented 359 cases of torture
by the Muslim Brotherhood regime during
its one year in power by way of
comparison this was 10 times more than
the number of cases documented annually
during the notoriously brutal regime of
H Mubarak in light of the brotherhood's
willingness to engage in viol to further
its ends and the Sharia goal it shares
with violent Jihad organizations Mark
Lynch's recommendation that the US work
to strengthen the Brotherhood as a
bullwark against Al-Qaeda is the height
of folly it would be tantamount to
aiding musolini in order to defeat
Hitler or electing Hillary Clinton in
order to roll back the policies of
Barack Obama by contrast the Muslim
Brotherhood terrorist designation Act is
more realistic quotes testimony from
former FBI director Robert Mueller who
stated that the elements of the Muslim
Brotherhood both here and overseas have
supported terrorism supporters of
terrorism richly deserve the terrorism
designation mainstream analysts such as
Mark Lynch have led the us into numerous
policy blind alleys and need to be
decisively rejected now I'm Robert
Spencer